historically
dark has been
laser focused on delivering the fastest
performance possible end-to-end runtime
of a problem
[Music]
these sometimes has come at the cost of
less than optimal memory usage
which on occasion was deliberate
and afterthought
first before i start is how many people
in the room are already familiar with
task raise your hands
okay not so bad
those that aren't
you may find yourself a bit disoriented
here as this is uh
quite a bit into the internal task
but tomorrow morning at 9 00 am there
will be a
tutorial from one of my colleagues that
starts from scratch and it's highly
recommended
so
those that already run
that's distributed may have already
found issues with
a lot of memory usage this is stemming
from
different reasons but the chief one is
that whenever you have
a task that finishes on a worker it will
leave its output on that worker when
another task on a different worker
needs the same data as an input
the task the data is copied off
let's look at it
so here i'm creating a cluster with two
workers
and i am submitting a task simply a
function that returns one
in this case i'm artificially saying i
want this task to run on worker zero
normally i wouldn't have that
specification i would just say
run this task on whatever worker is free
and ask would choose it
um
i wait for the to start the task to
finish the result is one
and then i query the cluster and ask
okay where is the data
of this task and they see that i have
the output on worker 0 and worker 1
doesn't have it it didn't run the task
it doesn't have no reason to contain a
copy so it doesn't have it
now i'm going to run a second
[Music]
task y
equal x plus one
now if i didn't put
these workers one
specif specific
task would notice that the cluster has
two workers
both of them are free worker 0 already
has all the input data worker 1 doesn't
so it would choose worker 0.
therefore avoiding a copy of the data
however let's say that worker 0 is
fairly busy and worker 1 isn't at that
point the ask will choose worker 1
because it will privilege
cpu
allocation
over the cost of memory transfers and
data duplication
in this artificial example i'm forcing
the copy from worker 0 to worker 1.
so i'm running
a
y on a worker 1 and that forces an
automatic copy of x
i didn't ask das to do the copy it just
happens because it really does realizes
that y requires x
so now i'm going to query again the
cluster
to see
what the data situation looks like what
do you think the output will be
we have y on worker 1 where it just
finished
we have the original copy of x on worker
0 and we have a new copy of replica of x
on worker 1.
i have two copies of x
and x in this case is a tiny integer but
in real life it may be hundreds of
megabytes worth of numpy
this is actually something desirable as
long as you have infinite amount of
memory
why well because if if in the future i
have another task that
also requires x
i won't need to transfer it again i
already have it on both workers so all
workers are ready hot and they can fire
off the new task straight away
if x was a transitory task
that meaning a task that is not
referenced by any client but is just an
input to something else
then the scheduler would delete it as
soon as possible but in this case x is
referenced by a client so it will stay
there indefinitely
um
other issues in
memory management that people may find
is that if you have a task that has
let's say 16 inputs and those 16 inputs
were computed on 16 different workers
dusk will have no option but to
get those 16 outputs and copy them over
onto a single worker
and that will cause a memory spike on
one of the workers of the cluster
dusk array and does data frame
already mitigate this by having a
recursive
aggregation in all of the reductions if
you take
the a dot sum for example to
reduce the um
a data frame
at an array on the columns or on the
rows or whatever
uh
there you're under the hood you're
actually having
chunks of four and then four and
therefore recursively so exactly to
avoid this kind of coagulation of memory
onto a single worker
final problem that a lot of people may
have been stumbled upon already
is that
when a worker hits 60 percent memory
usage it will start spilling data to
disk
if that is not sufficient
and the worker hits 80
memory usage it will pause and refuse to
accept new tasks if that is not
sufficient and it hits 95 percent usage
uh it will be killed by the nanny
the idea being that that is preferable
for to have 100 at which point
theoretically the kubernetes watchdog or
whatever else you're using will kick in
and just to the killing
now when the process is killed
all the data that you have on that
worker is lost
good news
you are not going to experience a crash
in your computation because the
scheduler will notice that it lost a
work and all the data on it
and will just reshade it somewhere else
bad news you just lost al you just lost
a lot of time because you have to
rebuild whatever was on that worker
worse news
if this is a systematic problem now you
may have another worker that ends up
exactly in the same condition
to
solve all of this kind of problem we
came up with the active memory manager
amm
for short
is a daemon that runs every couple of
seconds in the scheduler it analyzes all
the tasks in the cluster that are in
memory
and asks its policies which is applying
a plugin system for suggestions
every policy goes through the tasks that
it cares about
and issues two kinds of suggestions to
the nmm
replicate
a task that is already in memory
on one more worker so if the task exists
on only one worker say
create a copy somewhere else if it
exists on two great three etc
uh it can ask to just create a copy
somewhere at the mm will choose whatever
the worker with the lowest memory usage
is
or it may ask for a specific worker or a
specific short list of workers
another the opposite suggestion that a
policy could do is to drop
a replica
this can only happen if you have at
least two replicas of the of a task
the ama will flat out refuse to delete
the last replica of a task
it will also flat out refuse to generate
more replicas than you have workers
there are
a lot of other
less more subtle
things that the amm will notice and will
use to reject a suggestion when it is
unwise
the whole idea being that a policy
can be as sophisticated as you want in
terms of decision-making process
progress
whereas the amm
doesn't know about
decision-making that is on why the
policy decided to drop or replicate
but it it was guarantees the stability
and robustness of the whole thing
and one of the key features of mm is
that you can run it while the
computation is running you don't need to
push a button like for example client
that replicate which is something that
exists today
it just runs on its own every two
seconds and it's guaranteed to be
performed
and stable
for the same sake of simplicity there is
no
move
suggestion you have replicate or copy if
you prefer and drop if you want to do a
move first you do a replicate
second iteration two seconds later you
do a drop
the condition may have changed two
seconds later so you
your same policy may realize actually i
don't want to drop that key anymore i
want to drop another or
i am i want to do something else
entirely
the cluster evolves over time and the
policies over time will take different
decisions
mm
is at the moment
experimental feature which is off by
default
if you want to play with it all you need
to do is flick the switch
you can do it by through the dusk config
by simply setting the flag here
as shown
or on the fly even from the client
client.amm.start
that's it you need a fairly recent
version of dusk
what i am demoing is 2022.2
onwards
alternatively you can set the config
from the command line or if you're using
coiled as i will in the demo a second in
a few minutes
you can pass the environment variable
through the coiled
cluster creation
so as i said the amm in and by itself
is
very dumb in terms of decision making
actually doesn't do any decisions it
just asks the policies for decisions
and then enacts them
what policies
do we have well at the moment we have
two policies in
available in the package which are
remove replicas and retire walker
and we have plans in the future for two
more rebalancing replicate
on top of that this is a plugin system
and it is designed
to let the users add their own policies
for example
you may have a hybrid cluster
where some hosts are gpu enabled and
have not so great
memory and other workers don't have a
gpu and have a much larger memory
capacity or something like that
and you may say
well i want to
replicate these task that is contains
gpu specific data
on a short list of workers which is only
those that have a gpu
or you may say
yes i want to replicate this
cpu generic data but please avoid the
gpu specific
workers because on those memory comes at
a premium
or whatever else may come to mind or you
may say you may have some data that you
know is very very expensive to pickle
and unpickle
and you say actually skip this one
just shuffle around the numpy data that
is quick to serialize
first policy that we have
right now is amm remove replicas
and
it is on by default all you need to do
is activate
the active memory manager and you will
just have it running every two seconds
what does it do whenever you have two
plus copies of
a task
in memory
it drops the extra one if it deems them
not useful in the immediate future
this
drastically reduces the memory
consumption in the cluster and that's
something i will show in a second
retail worker is something that you may
actually have already used even if
without realizing
it is the back end of client.retire
workers and
it is used also by the adaptive scaler
whenever you scale down a cluster
it
is at the core of what we call graceful
worker retirement meaning unlike when
you kill a worker and you lose
everything
when you
decide to retire a worker and you have
some time and the worker is still
working
you can flush out all the data to the
rest of the cluster and then shut it
down without losing anything
in the future
we want to add rebalance which is a
complete overhaul of what currently is
the client.3 balance command
we want to get rid of the command
entirely
and instead have this thing that runs
every two seconds and continuously moves
data
from the workers that have the highest
memory usage to the workers that have
the lowest so that
the problem with
spikes in single workers of memory
should be a lot less visible
and finally replicate
is going to re-implement the current
client.replicate command
so you have some very precious data that
took a lot long a lot of time to
complete but you have some stability
issues in your cluster you can say okay
have four copies at all times of this
piece of data
and
unlike the current replicate command
whenever you lose a copy
amm replicate will regenerate the copy
continuously until you have four or
whatever many you ask for
for example
how will these policies
work together
uh
you have something that licks memory
and leaks memory very severely and you
end up over time with 80
of your memory
uh in leaks
it's not long no longer usable it just
sits there so the worker is paused it
gets stuck there in post state because
there is nothing to spill it's a memory
leak
after 30 seconds or so it transitions
into graceful retirement this is
something that we hope to deliver in q3
and retired worker takes all the data
all that valuable data that was sitting
on that worker
and
shuffles it out to the rest of the
cluster then that worker is shut down
uh replicate
will recreate whatever knowing whatever
data that was there that now has less
than the desired number of replicas
in the meantime the worker goes back
online
and it comes up online a brand new
worker and is completely empty
a mm rebalance will see that there has
the rest of the cluster with a
substantial
amount of memory and a completely empty
worker will take some data from the rest
of the cluster and put it
on the new work
all right now i will
show you
uh
the
re
reduce replicas policy
i am
gonna use a coil cluster here i'm
actually gonna use two parallel coil
clusters uh that are
16 workers two threads per worker a per
six gigabytes of worker perfectly
identical except for
this one weird trick
which is enabling
the amm
for all other purposes they are
perfectly identical
i have started them ahead of time to
save three flight three minutes
okay
and now i'm gonna test
okay client one amm is not running
client to it is running
now i'm gonna define a square matrix of
a bit less than six gigabytes
with dusk array
and now i'm gonna put it in tensor dot
with itself
this is a particularly brutal
exercise
because tensor dot is a n-squared
computation
where every chunk
needs to be put together with every
other chunk
so all the nice ideas behind the ask of
a worker does not need the
worker contains only a bit of bit of the
whole data set
fly out of the window every worker
eventually will need the whole data set
but we need to be careful not to have it
at the same time because we simply don't
have the space to store it
and now i'm going to
send them to the two clusters in
parallel
on the left i have the memory usage on
the cluster without amm
on the right
the exact same computation in the
cluster with amm
and
bar goes orange when it goes beyond 50
if it reaches 60 percent it starts
spilling if it reaches 80 percent it
poses if it reaches 95 percent it dies
and we can see how it is
less
memory intensive on the right
and once it is finished
we will be able to see the differences
on top of each other
i used a
small example so just
wouldn't take
the
entirely entirety of the
presentation
it's on the
starting to dwindle down
and we can see how
more or less at all times
the one with amm
[Music]
is somewhat
less memory hungry but now we will
see them on top of each other
and here you go
um
in the initial period the initial part
there is not much different but
once you get
what's to get to the core of the
computation you see the difference
this is the total memory usage the sum
of the memory across all every workers
and you see how the one with amm caps
out at 46 47 gigabytes whereas the one
without goes
fairly high
are there
questions
maybe
somebody wants to
sorry
microphone
where are you
uh so then you mentioned that rebalance
will
basically
try and take
workers that have high memory usage and
distribute the keys amongst other
workers but i'm assuming this only works
for workers that completed their task
or
how would it work if the keys are
necessary for actually doing the
computation
so
these uh
the mm avoids tasks that are just just
being copied over to a worker to serve
as an input to other tasks we're talking
about tasks that individually are
addressed
the cluster itself is not at rest you
have a computation going on
but
if you have a task that is a dependency
of another task that is skewed
it is completely ignored by the imm
and reverse the traditional algorithms
of
plane that's distributed
all right thank you
yeah thank you
how do you define a custom policy or
register one
you
need to follow a
dac api duct tape doctype api and you
just you have access to the list of the
tasks on the scheduler
and
you can define a policy you can define
you can go through them well in the
i would not recommend to go through all
of the tasks on the scheduler
sequentially
but
you can track for example a subset of
tasks that you're interested in or you
can have your own memory structures to
keep to keep them in check we have
additional memory structures for example
specifically for tasks that have more
than one replica running and you can tap
on those
and once you got to your decisions you
just yield them back
to the
amm all of those
are thoroughly documented in the
distributed page of emm
with plenty of examples
so we have a few from
slidell
what is the best reduction in peak
memory consumption that you have seen in
practice using amm
um
first and foremost
in practice is
a hard question because this is a is
disabled by default for obvious
uh concerns in terms of
stability
and i every time i see a
crowd like this i try to push please
play with it and come back to me and
tell me if it breaks
tensor dot is probably one of the
biggest
examples
in as a general rule if you have an
embarrassingly parallel computation amm
will make no difference whatsoever
because
if it's embarrassingly parallel most
times
you will not have data transfers at all
you have the beginning of you have a
bunch of siloed computations and every
worker can just take one
if you have something which any any kind
of n-squared problem
will benefit the most because those are
the ones that need to copy around most
data
thanks
one more
what do you mean by the worker will keep
valuable data what is valuable data
uh that is entirely up to you to define
but say for example
you have a first stage of a computation
that took you
five hours to complete
and you have a second stage of a
computation which is
performed by a c extension which has a
habit of sex faulting once in a while
you
[Music]
don't want to lose those five hours
just because a sec fault killed the
worker with the one and only copy of the
data on it
what you said you want to do is say okay
have four copies at this point and
oh you have a sec fault fine just
restart the worker copy the data over
somewhere else and now you have three
copies back to 4 amm replicate
and uh one more from slido
will amm be affected by storage backhand
being used for example tsar
um really uh
as long as your data is in ram uh
will mm will not really notice mm does
handle
a special logic for data that is spilled
to disk
so if you spill something to disk you
there will be decisions that change
space namely you will not have data that
is moved around if it's built to disk
unless absolutely necessary
because you will not get any any run
back it's already on disk
okay
we have time for one more question from
the audience if there is one
i i was wondering where the
the policies that you that you use where
coming from and if you take any
uh inspiration from other distributed
framework i'm i'm coming more from the
spark world and i'm wondering if you
took some of them from there or
some other one no not really in previous
jobs monte carlo is
very very heavily
monte carlo computations tend to be very
very heavily embarrassing embarrassingly
power
parallel most
calculations 95 of the calculation is
embarrassingly powered parallel there so
not really
this is specific when you start having
uh matrix dot products or such
um
i will
maybe you can ask it later because we
have another talk in 10 minutes
let's thank guido for his excellent talk
excellent presentation